we're now at the end of what has turned
out to be seven videos on certain
Kierkegaard's philosophical fragments my
favorite work by Kierkegaard and one
that I think actually brings together a
lot of the the really important themes
in his work and so what we're going to
do in this is consider what he calls the
disciple at second hand the case of the
second hand disciple and what we'll see
is that there actually is no disciple at
second hand according to Kierkegaard by
the very end so before we do that a
little bit of review a little bit of
recounting of where we've come he
distinguished from the very beginning
between a Socratic way of looking at
things where the teacher reveals to the
student what the student actually
already knows what already is in the
student the teacher doesn't give
something to the student that the
student didn't have the teacher merely
takes them out of the error that they
were in and leads them to the truth
that's within themselves and the teacher
then becomes you might say supplementary
or no longer needed that it can be
replicated indefinitely he contrasted
that against a sort of religious way of
looking at things where the teacher is
providing to the students something the
student couldn't possibly have doesn't
have within themselves reveals to them
the condition that they're actually in
and shows them that the the roots of the
error lie ultimately within within
themselves and their relationship to
something greater than them that teacher
can never be replaced
that teacher always needs to stay you
might say at least on the horizon and
can't be passed on can't be replicated
in in terms of the merely human and then
of course we talked about other ways of
teaching and learning and he said that
these are all inferior ultimately to
even the Socratic so the Socratic is the
highest that that human beings on their
own human reason unaided could could
bring about
the religious opened up an entire new
dimension in which all of these these
things can be situated in which the
socratic could be made sense of in which
the gaps that it's not able to perceive
could be taken into account in which
some sort of what he calls happy passion
of Understanding between the paradox
which is God and reason or consciousness
the human being could take place through
faith and along with that was the
possibility of offense anytime that
there's the possibility of faith there's
likewise that the possibility of offense
where there's an unhappy relationship
between the paradox and the human being
so now he is bringing us to the point
where he wants to ask about how it is
that we learn from each other that we
pass on things that we might call
traditions that anything like
institutional religion could have could
have a role in people's lives and
Kierkegaard is going to again as he's
done before take a very radical position
for a Kierkegaard every single believer
if they really are a believer have to be
in effect where the first believers were
we're that first generation who actually
walked and ate and communicated and were
puzzled by and were sorrowed
and Andrew belated bye-bye this God you
know become man this God entered into
time every single believer has to if
they are truly a believer for
Kierkegaard they have to be there that
doesn't mean that they have to be at
that point in time or that they have to
you know say address in the the clothing
of first century ad Palestine or talked
that way or maybe not even necessarily
use the same sort of concepts but the
relationship of faith that he's
sketching out has to has to be like that
so let's see how he actually gets there
he talks about the contemporary
disciples contemporary Christians in
this case and he says we have to figure
out you know how is it that that there
can be the same experience the same
fundamental relation the same connection
to the divine in 1843 or you know we
might say in 2013 he as was possible in
AD 33 how can this actually be the case
and he says this is the disciple not
only a second hand but you know you can
multiply the generations right so he
says let's think about the relation
between the secondary disciple and the
contemporary disciple and let's look at
the differences between them and how
they are also similar so he says we're
we're going to cut off the discussion
and it's not in an arbitrary place he
says for this reason it's not arbitrary
to cut off the discussion where we
please the relative differences the the
going from one generation to the next to
the next to the next the relative
differences here in question constitute
no story taste now what does a story
taste a story taste is an extended
argument where you say well if a then
this is just one example of a story
taste if a holds then B holds and if B
holds then C holds
we know that if a then C and now let's
add another joint to it and say well if
C then D and if D then e and we know
that C actually holds now because we
started that way over here so we can
jump from there to there and you can
have all sorts of arguments that have
long complicated structures with many
steps along the way those are story
tastes in traditional art arguments
studies you know rhetoric and logic so a
so if we don't actually have a story
taste here there's no new quality that
can be made to emerge because they're
all comprised within a common quality
everybody's in the same sort of case he
says a story taste would arise only if
we subjected the concept of contemporary
nante of actually being present in time
in relation with the the event to a
false dialectic and what would be some
examples of this you could for example
try to show that in a certain sense
nobody could be a contemporary because
nobody could be contemporary with every
moment or phase so you could set up what
will we call a sophism a false type of
argument a misleading type of argument
say well unless somebody is contemporary
in every single sense at every single
moment of time they're not really a
contemporary so therefore nobody is a
contemporary of Christ nobody's a
contemporary of the teacher another way
you could say where does the
contemporary leave off and the non
contemporary contemporaneity begin
you're trying to do you know impose some
sort of rigid dividing line between the
two of them you know did for example
Peters household you know who heard
about Christ that weren't actually in
his presence
were they contemporaries or were that
contemporaries you know for instance the
Centurion right or all the people that
were later on converted in the book of
Acts
would they be not contemporaries or
would they be contemporaries Kierkegaard
says really that's that's Mis
the point to frame it like that another
way would there exist a Twilight Zone
subject to bargaining of which the
parading understanding might say to a
certain degree and so forth so you know
can you say well somebody is kind of a
contemporary of that the teacher or the
paradox but maybe only 95 percent and
this person over here is 75 percent and
this person is even less once you start
trying to look at it in those sorts of
ways Kierkegaard would say you're
missing the point you're framing things
according to what he called the false
dialectic you're framing things in such
a way as to prevent yourself from
actually seeing what's going on and
understanding what it is that he's he's
saying so he says all these inhuman
profundities lead nowhere or perhaps in
our day they may lead to a reputation
for genuine speculative insight you know
he's bashing the the contemporary
philosophers of his time so instead what
are we going to do we're going to look
at a few basic features of the
contemporary disciple the disciple who
is connected with the teacher who walks
eats sleeps spends time with with him
am the disciple at second hand or third
hand or fourth hand is the disciple who
who's removed so he says let's look at
the first generation of secondary
disciples that's the the really key
thing to focus on because everybody is
in the same sort of boat right if you're
gonna say well we didn't see it
firsthand in a way it doesn't matter how
many hands it passes through there's
first hand and then there's all the
other hands so he says the generation
that comes immediately after enjoys the
relative advantage of being nearer to an
immediate certainty of being nearer to
the attainment of an exact and reliable
account of what happened from witnesses
whose reliability is subject to
collateral control but he says to be
nearer in this way is actually an
illusory advantage
for he who is not so near to immediate
certainty as to be immediately certain
as absolutely separated from it
you can't according to Kierkegaard sort
of build up probabilities and then wind
up with certainty at the end he says
suppose we try to estimate the value of
this relative difference that which
marks the first generation of secondary
disciples over against later ones how
great a value shall we assign to it well
we can evaluate it only by comparing it
with the advantage enjoyed by a
contemporary so we can only make sense
of this by looking at you know what
somebody who actually was there who is
an eyewitness would have received what
they're the sort of touchstone so he
says let's take a thought experiment
again you know one of these made-up
panic cases suppose there lived a man in
the immediately success succeeding
generation who combined at his own
person a tyrants power with a tyrants
passion and suppose this man and somehow
conceived the idea of concentrating his
entire time and energy upon the problem
of bringing the truth to light on this
point would this constitute him a
disciple he goes even further suppose he
possessed himself of all the
contemporary witnesses still living
together with the immediate circle of
their associates suppose he subjected
them one by one to the most searching
Inquisition shutting them up in prison
like the seventy interpreters that is
the the translators of the Septuagint
starving them in order to make him tell
the truth confronting them with one
another in the craftiest possible manner
all for the sake of making sure by every
possible means of a reliable account now
this is an interesting sort of image
isn't it and you know you have to do a
lot of imagining to make this actually
work who does this really seem like in
our own time this actually seems like
certain schools of of scholarship
doesn't it the idea is if we can just
assemble enough reliable you know
witnesses and subject them to the most
techniques
are going to bring out you know all the
possible little contradictions and and
you know collate and examine all this
sort of stuff we can sort of weed out
the the things that are false or
unreliable from the things that we can
say we have absolute certainty about
this and maybe some of them we have to
say it's probable will that actually
give you the the person that it's
supposed to give you will those sorts of
techniques apply to the New Testament
witnesses and all the other things that
you could possibly find connected to
that and what those actually provide you
with the connection to the reality of
who this guy Jesus was the the
connection between God and man in time
so he says even if the fact that we were
to speak of were a simple historical
fact this is a really interesting
insight here that he is even if it were
just talking about a single historical
fact like think about a case at law
right what do you notice about witnesses
if you've actually served at any sort of
not necessarily a jury but some sort of
panel where you have to cross-examine
people and you have to try to get to the
the story of what took place one of the
things that you want to figure out
fairly quickly on is that when stories
are perfect when they provide you with
complete certainty they're usually lies
and when they're small inconsistencies
that actually don't seem to lead
anywhere necessarily small
inconsistencies and contradictions in a
person's account and then the other
person's account odds are they're
actually telling the truth because
reality is complicated and our memory of
it is is often you know somewhat
unreliable yeah and the only person who
really has a stake and making sure that
they're absol their story is absolutely
airtight if somebody does actually try
to fool you
somebody who's trying to get one over on
you so he you know Kierkegaard talks
about this and he says it's a familiar
fact that the most conscientious and
truthful of witnesses are the first to
involve themselves in contradiction when
subjected to Inquisitor really and
questioned in the light of an
inquisitors fixed idea that doesn't mean
that they're not true that means that
the Inquisitor is actually by their sort
of insistence by their sort of
everything has to fit into these
categories they're actually producing
the falsity they're that they're going
to charge the person with on the other
hand it's the prerogative of a hardened
criminal on account of the precision
which with which an evil conscience tend
to enforce not to contradict himself in
his life the people who are actually the
most consistent the people who are
actually you know the most sure of
themselves are usually the ones who are
either you know complete saints which
are fairly rare or the complete bastards
the people who you know have lied to
themselves over and over again so much
that they actually believe their lies
the rest of us are kind of you know
neither here nor there and you know that
we can expect the same thing of the
witnesses to the the teacher the paradox
who comes into history so he says
putting all this aside let's say that
this tyrant this imaginary person was
able to get this this account with
perfect precision if he succeeded in
bringing to pass a complicated account
consistent to the letter and to the
minute he would beyond doubt be deceived
he would have obtained a certainty even
greater than was possible from a
contemporary observer there's always
this notion that scholars seem to have
that we're going to examine the
documents and the witnesses and sort of
coerce them into an account and we'll
have a better understanding of things
than Peter or Paul or any of the other
people you know around that time
because they were you know not as smart
as us and this was common back in
character guards time just as it's
common in our own time so he says if you
actually think about this what would an
account like that be a contemporary
would constantly be reminded he did not
see or hear the God immediately but
merely a humble human being who said of
himself that he was the God in other
words he would be constantly reminded
that the fact in question was based on a
self-contradiction would this man then
gain anything by reason of the
reliability of his account he's talking
about the tyrant again historically
speaking yes but otherwise now why not
well because you know like he points out
there are several important features of
this kind of account that's important he
says divinity is not an immediate
characteristic you can't look at
something and say AHA there's God you
have to be ready to recognize AHA
there's God you have to be willing to
sort of extend yourself to not be
scandalized by by the divinity the
teacher must develop in the learner the
most profound self-reflection the sense
of what sin there's there's a what
Kierkegaard is saying there's a notion
here that without consciousness of what
one really is a sinful human being one
can't recognize the divinity when it
presents itself to one pride its career
it isn't using these terms these are
sort of earlier categories that you find
the medievals talking in in terms of
pride keeps one from being able to
recognize God where God shows up
humility is what opens the possibility
for that humility doesn't mean self
abasement humility means recognizing
oneself as one truly yes
what about miracles so as a miracle does
not exist for immediate apprehension but
only for faith so it takes this this
happy passion of faith this
understanding that it provides to be
to rightly read the signs you might say
so what's the advantage then of the the
generation that he's talking about he
says they are the relative advantage in
one way of being nearer to the shock
produced by the impact of our fact when
Christ comes in many ways not just in
one way but in many ways he is a scandal
a shock he you know as a divider as well
as you know a uniter the very notion of
God becoming man it seems to be
logically you know self contradictory at
least in the way that it was understood
there so this this is a shock so the
shock connotes reverberations will help
to arouse the attention so the attention
is aroused the significance of such an
aroused attention has already been
evaluated before in in chapter 4 where
he's talking about the you know
contemporary disciple and he says this
advantage is not really an advantage why
not if you think about it in terms of
time you know you have the paradox
coming into history the eternal entering
into you know human history God becoming
man fully God fully man yeah and the
contemporary disciple is there in the
disciple who's there at the time they
are close to the to the shock the the
event that takes place now this shock
can go one of two ways and for each
person at any given point in time
undergoing that shock because of the
attention that they're giving it it goes
one of two ways so he says the advantage
from the shock is dialectical like the
aroused attention itself it consists in
having one's attention aroused whether
the result is that one believes or it is
offended
so both faith or offense
he and result from this many did believe
many didn't believe so the advantage is
like he says that a state of mind is
induced in which the crucial nature of
the decision confronting the individual
becomes more clearly evident things are
brought to a crux that's the only
advantage and like he says it's an
illusory advantage for the contemporary
disciple or the disciple immediately
afterwards now he goes fast forward all
the way down to the last generation so
you know the last generation for him is
that his his contemporaries of what he
called Christendom the last generation
for us would be you know contemporary
world the Christians that we know or you
know not just the Christians that we
know anybody who comes in contact with
the the the message and is going to
think about it so I did include a lot of
atheists as well so long as they keep
thinking about even if they're
constantly rejecting it they're they're
still part of that generation and if
this video you know survives 200 years
and somebody seeing it well then this
would be about third generation right so
Kierkegaard is saying the last
generation now he says if God comes into
the world as the absolute paradox then
nothing changes that nothing that
happens subsequently can avail to change
this the consequences will in all
eternity remain the consequences of a
paradox so the same situation is being
offered to disciples at secondhand a
third hand all the way down to whatever
hand we happen to be at right now
there's what appears to be an advantage
coming from this what's the advantage
he calls this naturalization which means
that things get easier what did we mean
by this well remember Kierkegaard is
somebody who is arguing for Christianity
and he's always arguing against
christened um what he sees as a culture
that has made Christianity as a way of
actually living thinking choosing being
in the world coming into existence as we
saw before
too easy easier than it ought to be and
therefore changed it in the process
taking people away from genuine
Christianity so he says the advantage of
the consequences what are the
consequences the consequences are you
know throughout history people you know
think about for example you know when
Christ first came on the scene and said
forgive your enemies that was a pretty
radical thing to say and you know when
He healed the the year of the the the
servant that had been cut off by one of
his own guys you know trying to defend
him that was an example of that
how many goes and gets you know gets
crucified gets gets killed and so saying
you know you should forgive your enemies
that was really scandalous at the time
in many ways it's a hard saying as they
they say well some of the hard sayings
get made easier now imagine that you're
within a culture where that becomes the
norm because it's been so thoroughly
Christianized that everybody is you know
now trying to forgive their enemy
all that now some people would say well
see that culture has actually embodied
Christianity and made in advance and
it's going to be easier for the
disciples at that you know second hand
or you know whatever hand to sort of
embrace this and Kierkegaard says that's
not an advantage either
that's an illusory advantage he says if
such is the case if this sort of thing
actually could be what takes place the
latter generation has a direct advantage
over the contemporary generation under
the assumption of naturalization it
would be possible for a later generation
keep going long enough to appropriate
the fact without the slightest
embarrassment without seeing anything of
the ambiguity of the aroused intention
without going through that shock I'm
saying holy crap what the hell is this
that Christianity at least as
Kierkegaard sees it makes a person have
to go through and then you know having
to go through the am I going to accept
and try to embrace and understand and
allow myself to be transformed not only
in my actions but also even in my mind
by this or am I going to find a fence
with it
and say this can't possibly be I am
smarter than this this is this is folly
you know any any sort of thing like that
well let's say you could give somebody a
nice hand book after a while though to
say okay you're going to go through this
this moment and you're gonna be tempted
to be offended but don't do that because
look look here's where you want to go
and that was effective every single time
well then it really wouldn't be a choice
now would it there would be no real
shock there would be no awareness of
one's own condition Christianity would
have become as he says naturalized he
says of the paradox it is and it remains
the paradox and it cannot be assimilated
by any speculation even by angles angles
that you know a very good job trying to
make a case for that but Kierkegaard
says it doesn't work this face
this fact of the paradox exists for
faith alone faith may indeed become the
second nature he says of a man but the
man in whom it becomes a second nature
must surely have had a first nature in
order to be able to have faith in order
for a nature to become transformed super
naturalized you might say enter into
relation of fertilizing relation with a
supernatural you actually have to have a
nature and that nature does Christianity
you know tells me that as the paradox
reveals it is a damaged nature so
damaged that it continues its own damage
within itself and even when it tries to
understand the damage unless it actually
accepts the helps that it needs from the
from the paradox
it makes the damage even worse that's
not going to go away according to
Kierkegaard so he says if this is if all
this is the case everything that we
we've proposed in the first chapter
would be confounded if you actually
could overcome you know all the scandal
of Christianity just by waiting around
long enough for everybody to sort of
take it in and be okay with it then all
the other stuff he's saying wouldn't
make sense let's go on so he says the
advantage afforded by the consequences
is dubious for another reason - insofar
as the consequences don't actually
follow directly as simple consequences
and again we say the same move as with
the the tyrant who wanted to have that
perfect account the trouble is in order
to to see things that pertain to faith
the paradox the supernatural as such you
actually have to interpret you actually
have to extend yourself there's no you
know smack you in the face and tell you
see here it is here's the evidence you
actually have to be able to you have to
be willing to see evidence as evidence
for it to count as evidence
so he says the advantage afforded by the
consequences is dubious for another
reason let us discuss the advantage of
the consequences at its highest maximum
and assume that this fact is completely
transformed the world so you've had this
continual progression in which
Christianity has sort of reached its its
claws into the culture and change things
and modified the very ways in which
people understand themselves and in
which they they conceive of their
relations with other people society all
these sorts of things right so
Christianity becomes progressively less
and less scandalous how does this come
to pass this is a really good question
so surely not at once I mean that's not
the way history takes place that's not
the way revolutions take place right all
at once now it takes place with a bunch
of steps a bunch of you know in advance
here and in advance here and in advance
here and in advance here and oftentimes
a lot of pushback you know an example of
this would be what monasticism developed
as and then brought into Western culture
a lot of which has been lost
unfortunately brought into Western
culture by being sort of the ones who
are passing on learning the ones who
were embodying how to live a society in
which people could more or less get
along with each other and if you
actually read some of the letters that
these monks wrote to each other this was
not easy they actually you know didn't
always get along you know it wasn't it
wasn't heaven on earth so anyway by a
succession of steps how are these these
steps taken this is a very important
point by each particular generation
again coming into a relationship with
this fact with the paradox every
generation that is going to transform
the world and in some sense whatever
that may be make it more Christian and
make it easier to understand the
Christian message and the Christian
choice and the Christian Way of life
every generation that does that
can only do that by their relationship
of faith with God with the paradox by
embracing the paradox and making that
part of their practice and their theory
and their community so he says this
intermediary determination must be
brought under control or may not a
misunderstanding also have consequences
made out of lie also be powerful and has
it not happened so to each generation if
now the previous generations
collectively proposed to bequeath to the
last the whole splendid array of
consequences without further ado
wouldn't that represent on this
understanding you know I have for
example in my my library the collected
works of the ant and I seen in post may
see and father's that I happen to get in
to steal from from I think it's
Christian booksellers distributors or
something like that and that doesn't
make me any better of a Christian or
even necessarily offer me an
understanding of Christianity even if I
worked my way and I probably won't work
my way in my lifetime yet although I
want to do this through all those
volumes and read all those great you
know Saints and fathers and doctors who
really lived a life you know devoted to
developing their relationship than the
divine I really have a lot to say about
a lot of intelligence stuff it's not
going to do me any good according to
Kierkegaard unless I've also developed
that relation as well unless I'm reading
them through the lens which is provided
by that if I'm reading them merely as a
historian or as a philosopher or even he
has what a lot of people think of as a
theologian I'm gonna miss something I
may learn a lot but I'm going to miss
what's at the heart of it
so he says something really interesting
here consequences found another paradox
are humanly speaking founded over built
over a yawning chasm and their total
content which should be can which can be
transmitted to the individual only with
the express understanding that they rest
on a paradox are not to be appropriated
as a settled estate not something where
you can say oh yeah I get this and it's
my inheritance and I just kind of live
it out you know a lot of a lot of people
who grow up within a religious tradition
have that sort of view that you know I
know everything that there is to know
about this because I grew up with it
well unless you've actually assimilated
it and struggled with it and thought
about it and been puzzled about it and
he had to go beyond yourself and not
just to somebody else but go beyond
yourself to God to make sense out of it
Kierkegaard would say you're actually
not getting it that inheritance doesn't
do you any good let's go a little bit
further now so he talks now about the
first generation of secondary disciples
again he says they have this advantage
the difficulty is always there and that
you know the fact that it is difficult
that's actually an advantage if we go on
to the problem of the disciple at second
hand all right we've got this sort of
viewpoint here we want to try to figure
out what is their relationship to to the
divine is it mediated solely through the
other generation of contemporary
disciples and he says we have to think
about this in terms of history and time
and the absolute so one of the things
that he says here I'm actually skipping
over some material he says if the fact
in question is an absolute fact or
determinate for more precisely if it is
the fact that we have described namely
that the absolute enters into time into
history into human meaning that God
becomes fully man
it would be a contradiction to suppose
that time had any power to differentiate
the fortunes of man with respect to it
that is to say in any decisive sense so
if this is an absolute fact then that
fact has to be just as accessible for
anybody coming along later on as it was
for the one who was right there at that
point at what we call the Christ event
so he says the absolute fact is also a
historical fact must we're careful to
insist on this point our entire
hypothesis is nullified and then we
speak only of an eternal effect so he's
making a difference between an absolute
fact and eternal fact and an historical
fact and these are these are all
interconnected so the absolute fact is
it is a historical fact and as such it
is for what the object of faith so it's
not a historical fact in the same sense
as Washington Crossing the Delaware and
somebody writing about that it requires
a person to actually extend themselves
in faith to that to interpret that as an
absolute fact so he says the historical
aspect must indeed be accentuated but
not in such a way it becomes decisive
for the individuals and neither can the
historical aspect of our fact be
eliminated for them we have only an
eternal effect this is what happens when
people try to turn Christianity or
trying to turn the the the figure of
Jesus Christ into you know the teacher
for all time was basically like Socrates
and Volta and pick whatever else you
like and you ignore the historicity you
ignore the fact that look this point in
time was chosen these actions were done
these sayings were said and preserved so
he says now just as this historical
gives occasion for the contemporary to
become a disciple but only it must be
noted through receiving the condition
from God itself what is the condition
becoming aware of one's on case that one
is sinful that one needs assistance that
one needs grace in order to to prosper
to to have the scales and a lifted in
order to make progress since otherwise
he says we speak Socratic Li
so the testimony of contemporaries gives
occasion fruits to each successor to
become a disciple but only it must be
noted through receiving the condition
from the God himself so what I'm going
to say I've been gesturing over here to
this this is the wrong way to look at it
Kierkegaard would say because the
question always becomes that at this
point well you know how is this how does
this guy or people or generation how
does the message come through them
because now we're talking about you know
human beings and how does this divine
message actually make it through them
and so this generation actually has the
same experience the same possibilities
the same fullness that this generation
have Kierkegaard says well it doesn't
that's not the way it works so this is
the better diagram right here you have
the paradox God God becoming man and the
paradox gives the condition to the
contemporary disciple you actually
realized what they are to set reason
what it needs to be set aside to have
the relationship then of faith
and then the contemporary disciple
passes something on to the other
disciple what they pass on is not faith
what they pass on is not the condition
what they do is they provide what
Kierkegaard says is an occasion they
they provide an instance they provide
some talking points they provide hey
let's let's let's explore this they may
provide sometimes a scandal you know
think about a Christian for example who
who acts the way that many Christians do
including including myself in ways that
are contrary to the message of
Christianity and is not you know
entirely reformed the way that we ought
to be another disciple you know
potential disciple might look at that
and say see those those damn Christians
there they're so full of it but somebody
else might lucky that and say how come
that person isn't like this person over
here who they're supposed to be
connected with man I want to be like
that person sometimes even scandalizing
another person can be an occasion for
them to receive the condition from God
and for them to develop a relationship
faith as well that's what Cooper Guard
is saying here so he says now we're
ready to begin this is deep in the
chapter he says now we're actually ready
to begin from the God himself everyone
receives the condition who by virtue of
the can who by virtue of the condition
becomes the disciple so the immediate
contemporaneity of the contemporary
disciple is merely an occasion what
becomes then of the the disciple at
secondhand he says for whoever he has
what he has from the god himself clearly
has it at firsthand right and he who
does not have it from the god himself is
not a disciple this is this is a big
problem if you
get it this way I'm gonna skip ahead and
then we're gonna come back and look at
some ways that that don't actually fit
this because he tells you what it is
that corresponds to this diagram that I
put there he says if we wish to express
the relations subsisting between a
contemporary and his successor and the
briefest possible compass but without
sacrificing accuracy to brevity we may
say the successor believes by means of
the testimony of the contemporary and in
virtue of the condition he himself
receives from God so by means of the
testimony that he gets from the
contemporary disciple or from other
generations prior to that right later
than that as well for instance think
about having the Bible right and the
Bible has to be written down the New
Testament in particular is coming you
know after yeah it has to be assembled
and then people have to keep writing it
and transmitting it and explaining it
that provides the means right in virtue
of the condition that the person
receives from the God is the person able
to have faith so he says the testimony
that contemporary provides an occasion
for the successor just as the immediate
contemporaneity
actually being there with with the the
paradox the god man provides an occasion
for the contemporary and he says if the
testimony is not of this nature that
it's either by a historian and it does
not deal essentially with the object of
faith as when a contemporary historian
who is not a believer recounts one or
other effect or it's by philosopher and
it doesn't deal with the object of faith
either only a testimony which is
providing an occasion in this in this
way and not trying to to wrap everything
up you know into the eternal or into the
purely historical can be the means for a
person to have this relationship of
faith with the God according to
Kierkegaard so he says there actually is
no disciple
second hand the first and last are
essentially on the same plane only that
a later generation finds its occasion in
the testimony of a contemporary
generation while the contemporary
generation found its occasion in its
immediate contemporary inanity and in so
far it was nothing to any other
generation now let's let's get back a
little bit I mean this is really
interesting stuff to say
every single person throughout all time
is in a position where they have just as
much access according to Kierkegaard to
the paradox to this transformative
capacities to the relationship that it
offers every single person whether they
were there and walked and ate with the
god man or whether they are off you know
million years from now so long as
there's actually some sort of testimony
still going on even if the testimony got
garbled in the process it doesn't matter
because the testimony is merely an
occasion the reality the god man the
paradox is what provides the condition
to whatever generation of believers were
talking about to actually develop in in
faith that's how things go right let's
look at a few ways in which things could
go wrong so he asks
how can things go go wrong if the
contemporary disciple gives the
condition to the successor then the
successor will come to believe in him
then that person assumes the role of God
they take the space of God and God could
so to speak just pop out of the picture
right we would erase the paradox and
perhaps this person then becomes the
paradise that's a form of idolatry carry
or it isn't isn't discussing it as such
but that's that's what we're in effect
talking about he says he receives the
condition from him and thus the
contemporary becomes the object of faith
for the successor such a meaningless
consequence will surely deter thought
from making this assumption here it says
no that's that's an interesting thing
for him to say particularly I think
that's not Kierkegaard himself talking I
think maybe that's Kierkegaard in the
guise of this this philosopher who's
exploring these things they says if on
the contrary the successor also receives
the condition from the God then the
Socratic relationships will return of
course within the total difference
constituted by the fact in question what
then can a contemporary do for a
successor he says he can inform him that
he has himself believed this fact which
is not in the strict sense of
communication but merely affords an
occasion for when I say that this would
that has happened I make a historical
communication but when I say and this is
important for triggered I believe when I
make an act of belief we would say when
I expressed that when I affirm them I
believe and he had believed that
so-and-so has taken place although it is
a folly to the understanding and an
offence of the human heart then I have
simultaneously done everything in my
power to prevent anyone else from
determining his own attitude and
immediate continuity with mind I'm not
bringing any pressure to bear if I tell
you when you ask me why do you believe
in Christianity and I say like your
gagarin is isn't saying you know
attributing this to Tertullian and I
know that people point
Tertullian isn't saying exactly this but
i believe because it's absurd I'm
certainly not making it easy for anyone
else to follow along with me and say oh
he thinks it's true so I'm gonna think
it's true too
I'm sort of like you know keeping people
at arm's distance and offering them the
possibility of figuring this this stuff
out for themselves so he says in this
form you can relate the content of the
fact but this content exists only for
faith this is really interesting too
when you read other people's conversion
narratives it may be that a portion of
that narrative only really make sense to
you when you've experienced something
similar and that's something similar
just in the sense of like yeah we all
went to camp together but something
similar that actually you know shocked
you and shook you and allowed you to be
formed and reformed as Anselm's his
works formed and reformed let's go on
now and so Kierkegaard is is bringing
these things to a close and he says
there is no disciple at secondhand how
are we going to end this and he says
yeah I'm going to actually finish just
by pointing out this thing he says it's
well known that Christianity is the only
historical phenomenon which in spite of
the historical name precisely by means
of the historical has intended itself to
be for the single individual that's a
very important Kierkegaard Ian theme
that we see the single individual who
has value in the eyes of the paradox the
point of the departure for his eternal
consciousness he's interested in the in
the historical and he's also interested
in the fact that we have eternal
consciousness and the consciousness that
we only truly grow into or understand or
or explore the contras of by means of
our relationship
to the paradox if we choose to be
offended we cut ourselves off from from
the actually exploring that eternal
consciousness if on the other hand we
choose the relationship of faith then we
open the door to that according to
Kierkegaard so here's where he's gonna
end he says no system of philosophy
addressing itself only to thought no
mythology addressing itself solely to
the imagination no historical knowledge
addressing itself to the memory has ever
had this idea the the paradox itself as
we saw back in you know chapter 3 the
paradox itself gives the idea this is a
gratuitous gift also coming in through
history this is a way in which
Christianity put something into or
before or offer to philosophy something
that could actually transform it that
could allow philosophy to be more than
what it had been just in the sort of
Socratic or later on a galleon mode
which was the highest that that
character God thinks man was capable of
the person of the god man coming into
time changes the landscape for
philosophy but only at philosophy is
willing to recognize that it's possible
for it to take offense and it's always
going to be you know somewhat uneasy and
at odds with it
this is where we see Kierkegaard again
doing what it is that that Christian
philosophers do according to certain
classical formulations of this that has
taken theological or religious reality
and try to come up with some sort of
philosophical understanding articulation
or
explanation of it that's what he's done
here in terms of all the themes that
we've discussed and finally in terms of
the relationship between these different
disciples back to the teacher throughout
time history and culture